talking about text if you really want to
reduce the number of file requests your
page makes you can inline images using
code two ways to do that SVG and data
URIs now here's a vector graphic you may
have seen before both versions look
identical and here they are in emulation
mode and here on a real phone looking at
the page source you'll see that the
logos are declared in line there's an
SVG and an image element with a data URI
source in line SVG has great support on
mobile and desktop browsers and
optimization tools can significantly
reduce SVG size spot the difference
these two inline SVG logos look
identical but one is around three
kilobytes and the other only about 2k
SVG is incredibly powerful check out
this interactive version of Trajan's
column works on mobile too and the best
thing all that responsive interactivity
for less than 160 kilobytes for more
amazing SVG examples check out the link
below the video data URIs provide a way
to include a file such as an image in
line as a base64 encoded string using
the following format the full version is
around 5,000 characters just like SVG
data URIs are well supported on mobile
and desktop browsers that's around well
nearly ninety seven percent of browsers
so you can inline images in your HTML
but data URIs and svgs can also be
inlined in CSS works on desktop and on
mobile here we have two
identical-looking images implemented as
background images in CSS one day to uri
and one SVG now the code looks a bit
crazy so why would you want to do this
well to reduce HTTP requests